let's now talk about the moral compass
there are two big things that Donald
Trump lacks one of the well there's more
but the two two of them are a sense of
humor we've seen no real evidence that
Donald Trump understands humor he has no
sense of humor
for any sort of satirical content about
him there's no evidence that Donald
Trump has a real sense of humor to speak
of and Donald Trump seems to lack a
moral compass or at least one that seems
in line with what the average Western
standard typical person's moral compass
should or we would hope looks like
Donald Trump's daughter Ivanka said to
the other day and she didn't say this
satirically she didn't say this
ironically she says that she got her
moral compass from her father Donald
Trump can you imagine anything more
horrifying this happened at a fundraiser
a couple of weeks ago the fundraiser was
at Jackson Hole Wyoming it was for
wealthy donors as is often the case for
these fundraisers particularly in states
like Wyoming and Devon K Trump was asked
one of these just BS bubblegum stupid
questions that makes donors feel like
they're engaging in dialogue and all of
this other stuff if you've been to these
fundraisers but you know what I mean and
Ivanka was asked can you share the
personality traits that you inherited
from your parents and again there's such
a meaningless vapid question but it
actually led to something and it
interesting Ivanka told the roomful of
donors that from her mother she
inherited the example of what it means
to be a successful woman and that from
her father Donald Trump she inherited
his moral compass think really deeply
about this for a second what do we mean
when we say a moral compass a moral
compass I see as the barometer that we
use to decide what is right and what is
wrong and to act in accordance with that
Donald Trump obstructed justice at least
eight times he's used the presidency to
enrich himself he's lied 10,000 times 12
thousand times according to a lie
tracker he praises dictators and
criticizes the leaders of Democratic
allies he cheats at golf he cheats at
relationships
cheats at businesses by using
undocumented immigrant labor but then at
the same time saying that he's against
it he is accused of sexually assaulting
close to 20 or maybe even more women
whatever moral compass led Donald Trump
to decide to do all of those things and
to somehow rationalize them publicly
refer himself that's the moral compass
that Ivanka says that she inherited from
him can you imagine what it is that
she's saying imagine being her husband
Jared Kushner although maybe his moral
compass is equivalent to her so maybe
even maybe this doesn't make sense but
imagine being Jared and finding out that
your wife has inherited her moral
compass from a guy who's moral compass
has been backwards just spinning around
for his entire life and I actually
believe Ivanka a lot of times at these
fundraisers in addition to vapid
ridiculous questions you get completely
meaningless BS answers I believe her I
think she's being honest she has the
same lack of a working moral compass
that Donald Trump has moving production
of her lame products to sweatshops
overseas using her father's presidency
to enrich herself and insert herself
into situations for which she is grossly
unqualified participating in the
distract Athan media circus every time
her father gets into some kind of hot
water I actually believe this she does
seem to have gotten her moral compass
from Donald Trump at least she is being
honest here and it is extremely
distressing and disgusting let me know
what you think is this just something
she's saying or has she really inherited
her moral compass from Trump and is that
something we should be very very scared
of